ci sono parole che fanno paura
una di queste è fallimento fallire io lo
so che se c'è qualche imprenditore
adesso in sala sarà toccando ferro ma la
mia storia una storia di fallimenti e io
ci ho dedicato quindici anni della mia
vita a fallire proprio bene ho capito
che mi piaceva a fallire
quando avevo vent'anni non sapevo chi
ero e quindi ho deciso di fare un
viaggio di andare lontano da tutti e
sono andata in thailandia non parlavo
una parola di thailandese non sapevo chi
ero
ma sapevo che avevo voglia di conoscere
le persone che avevo intorno e quindi ho
deciso un giorno che per farlo devo
comprare un pallone quindi ho comprato
un pallone io giocavo a calcio in italia
sono andata da un gruppo di ragazzini
che c'era in questo paesino sperduto
della thailandia e ho iniziato a giocare
con loro a calcio a un certo punto sono
rimasta allibita perché mi sono resa
conto che tutto il villaggio si era
radunato intorno ai bordi di questo
campetto è in una situazione tipo cinema
come se fossero al cinema solo che il
cinema
ero io e ho superato l'imbarazzo in
quella situazione ho continuato a
giocare con tutte le energie che avevo
in corpo ea un certo punto è successa
una cosa che mi ha cambiato la vita
sono caduta ma proprio bella lidi stesa
cosa è successo tutte le persone che
c'erano lì radunate all'unisono sono
scoppiati a ridere tutti hanno
cominciato a ridere di me io ho alzato
lo sguardo
sono rimasta pietrificata avrei voluto
che la terra si aprisse sotto di me e mi
mangiasse in un secondo
ma non è stato così e quindi ho fatto
l'unica cosa che potevo fare in quella
situazione
ho riso con loro in quel momento io ho
capito che nella mia vita avevo
finalmente trovato qualcosa che mi
piaceva questa caduta questo fallimento
ha segnato in me una forte presa di
coscienza e ho capito è che volevo fare
il clown perché il clown perché il
crowne mette in scena la propria
vulnerabilità e i propri fallimenti ride
con gli altri e creando un empatia
magica trova nuove soluzioni ai problemi
questo come lo fa lo fa in una manciata
di secondi in una manciata di secondi
quando arriviamo per un clown
abbiamo tre pensieri a livello inconscio
il primo è che è un fallito
abbiamo davanti a noi un idiota che sta
facendo una figuraccia
il secondo pensiero inconscio che
abbiamo è che realizziamo in quel
momento che anche noi almeno una volta
nella vita abbiamo fatto una figuraccia
per cui avremmo voluto che la terra si
aprisse ecc ingurgita se in
quell'istante la terza cosa la più
importante a livello inconscio in quella
manciata di secondi
noi ci rendiamo conto che anche altri
stanno ridendo con noi che anche altri
si sono sentiti nella vita dei falliti e
questo è questo crea una magia e
un'empatia che applicata alla vita di
tutti i giorni fa succedere delle cose
che se noi pensiamo a livello razionale
non le faremo accadere
e qui arriva la seconda parte del mio
racconto torno dalla thailandia cara
mamma caro papà io voglio fare claudio
voglio fallire
voi potete capire il dramma familiare
che che si creò nella provincia di
milano dove sono nata e cresciuta ma
supero questo imbarazzo
vado avanti e vengo a torino conosco
l'arte di strada mi formo faccio degli
stage e dei corsi e professionali più
teatro e iniziò a lavorare anche in
strada
sempre a torino incontro quella che è
diventata la mia socia di lavoro silvia
insieme creiamo una compagnia di teatro
di strada comico
al femminile che solo dieci anni fa era
abbastanza una novità questo perché
c'erano anche altre artiste comiche e
donne ma eravamo sicuramente una
minoranza e quindi grazie a questa cosa
anche subito entriamo nel mondo del
lavoro subito iniziamo a lavorare e ad
essere contattate da festival ed eventi
di teatro di strada e qui inizia il
nostro vero dramma perché solo dieci
anni fa
voi forse non sapete il grado disastroso
di percezione del nostro mestiere che
c'era a voi forse non è mai successo
alla domanda che lavoro fai ma io sono
un'attrice di teatro di strada faccio
clown la risposta al 99,9 per cento
delle volte era interessante ma di
lavoro che lavoro fai
e il dramma si consumava anche nella
relazione con i nostri committenti
perché vi assicuro che solo dieci anni
fa fare teatro di strada e ottenere un
contratto per questo lavoro sembrava
un'impresa degna di maria callas di una
diva del cinema anche di fronte a questa
difficoltà
cominciamo a riderne insieme ovviamente
facendolo di mestiere e iniziamo a
confrontarci con altri artisti di strada
qui a torino ci ridiamo sopra ne
parliamo e capiamo che abbiamo bisogno
di un pallone e ce lo creiamo in dieci
artisti di strada nel 2009 qua a torino
fondiamo la prima cooperativa di artisti
di strada
la prima in tutta italia noi ovviamente
non lo sapevamo mentre lo stavamo
facendo ma abbiamo scoperto negli anni
che abbiamo risposto ad un'esigenza
nazionale infatti da quei dieci primi
considerati i pazzi
ad oggi siamo 300 trecento artisti di
strada in tutta italia che grazie alla
cooperativa ricevono una tutela
amministrativa legale e contrattuale che
prima era veramente un traguardo che
sembrava irraggiungibile
e a conferma del nostro del nostro
lavoro e della nostra passione ed è
tutto il nostro impegno e fatica
tre anni fa abbiamo avuto un importante
riconoscimento perché siamo entrati nel
programma di sostegno del fus
riconoscimento ministeriale come prima
impresa di produzione di teatro di
strada prima in italia ad essere
composta al 90 per cento da artisti
stessi e non da committenti che dire
adesso voi mi vedete sono qui in
accappatoio e c'è un motivo
sono qui per vi presento diciamo un
piccolo estratto di uno dei miei
fallimenti con cui ho girato il mondo e
grazie al quale ho capito che cadere e
ridere davanti agli altri
non serve a farmi cadere di meno ma nel
mio piccolo ha trasformato quella caduta
in un volo grazie
[Applauso]
bene
ecco
all
[Musica]
[Applauso]